in our series on the new normal we'll
take a look at how the pandemic is
dramatically changing our everyday lives
airports and Airlines expect the 4th of
July holiday weekend to be the busiest
travel day since mid-march
but passenger traffic at about six
hundred and twenty six thousand people
on Wednesday is still a fraction of what
it was it's down about 75 percent from
last year
whoa so if you're planning to fly it's
gonna look a whole lot different Kris
Van Cleave is at Reagan National Airport
outside Washington was more on that part
of the story Kris can't wait to hear
what you have to say good morning to you
well good morning Gail I'm sure you
found your flying experience to be
different we sure did take a look around
here this is what a busy travel day
looks like now in the age of coronavirus
still millions of people are going to
travel for the fourth of July hundreds
of thousands we'll do it by air and you
know we went on our first work trip in
nearly four months and even from the
point we started packing it was
different you're grabbing hand sanitizer
and masks gloves even safety glasses
first flight since March
start to the temperature check and
before checking in I had to certify I
didn't have a fever or any other kovat
symptoms at the airport it's Plexiglas
barriers and reminders to keep your
distance flyers and masks and face
shields many stores and restaurants
remain closed TSA looks different too I
just want to be extra cautious wearing
gloves and carrying wipes we met Dana
Kaufman at the gate flying to Chicago to
see her parents finally get to see them
since I haven't seen them during the
corona virus pandemic before we got on
the plane was cleaned using an
electrostatic fogger like this to
quickly disinfect the cabin between
flights boarding was done back to front
flight attendants greeting you with
sanitizing wipes I brought my own to
wipe down the area around my seat no
question flying is different here we are
at the start of the fourth of July
holiday weekend and there are dozens of
empty seats on this plane we were struck
by how quiet the flight was everyone
wore masks as required
but United confirms it has banned a
handful of fliers for refusing to comply
with the masks mandate in flight service
is limited snack bags and bottles of
water we try to eliminate anything that
would pass germs basically our cabin
crew all on the job for at least 20
years what's the biggest thing you
notice that's changed about flying since
the pandemic the reduction in
passengers the biggest change is people
have been more cautious about their
safety and so I think that's very
important for all of us there's nobody
you know yeah it's this is the other
thing that people are going to notice
when they're traveling is it's not just
that people are wearing masks that there
aren't that many people not even at one
of the country's busiest airports at
9:45 in the morning we met United Steve
communications officer Josh earnest at
Chicago O'Hare what are you expecting
for fourth of July we are expecting an
increase that we have seen leisure
travel begin to come back we're also
seeing quite a bit of travel with people
wanting to go visit friends and family
it's also people who are enticed by many
of the attractive fares that are out
there there's a growing divide over
blocking middle seats Delta Southwest
and JetBlue are limiting capacity
American and United are not Delta CEO
telling employees in a letter Thursday
limiting capacity makes a real
difference in keeping travelers and our
people safe on board
look when our competitors talk about
blocking middle seats they're talking
about a PR strategy not a safety
strategy a safety strategy is one that's
focused on wearing masks and requiring
people to wear them correctly United
also points to its cleaning in the
onboard help of filters as part of that
safety strategy there are no regulations
mandating social distancing for Airlines
so every carrier is doing it differently
United does notify fliers if their
flight is 70% full or more allowing them
to make a change without a feat United
says only about two percent of flyers
make that change
Gayle Kris I find the question
interesting PR strategy versus safety
strategy I think psychologically even if
it's a PR strategy
it would make maybe more comforting to
people what are you hearing about that
and your own flying experience well I
think there are two things that are
going on here I think our definition of
what a full plane is has changed the
plane might have 20 or 30 empty seats
but be 85 percent full and 85 percent
seems like a lot of people on a 737
that's still a hundred and forty people
so that's there I think because every
airline has a different policy it
creates confusion so people getting on
necessarily know what to expect and
you've had some carriers that have you
know only blocked a small portion of
seats and that's led to confusion it's
really coming down to how airlines are
selling themselves they're selling
themselves around safety and spacing and
will people pay extra will they pay a
premium not to have somebody in that
middle seat that's the question now yeah
I know people used to do eye rolls when
people would come on in hazmat suits and
masks now people are asking where do I
get one of those thank you Chris was
good to see Josh Ernst - really good to
see him thank you Chris Van Cleve